So, I decided to take a look at cnn.com, a popular news
site. To get started, I opened up dev tools by pressing Cmd
+ Opt + I. You can see the dev tools here, here
is the HTML. So we're in the timeline now. I want to see
what happens when the page loads. So, I'm going to press Cmd+ Shift+
R, reload the page and we can see all of the events of
the page load. Laid out in the timeline here. Well, this is
cool for desktop, but I wonder what it looks like on mobile. Luckily,
Chrome gives us the option of seeing what it
looks like on mobile. I'm going to press this button
to open up the console, there we go, and
we can see that there's a tab up here, emulation.
So, I click on this, I see the Google
Nexus five, and I press emulate. So now, we're
looking at CNN.com from a mobile perspective. Bu,t this
looks weird. I'm going to fix the screen a little bit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And, I'm going to refresh the page, by doing
command shift r. And now, we see the mobile
version of CNN on the left. And our timeline
on the right. Let me get rid of this
bottom part by pressing escape. And move the screen
over to give ourselves a little more room. And
let's take a look at the timeline. So, I've
selected about the first second or so of events.
Let me see them in a little bit more detail.
Alright, so we see the request here for
a page cnn.com/, so I'm going to click on
this and open up the details, click on
cnn.com, and we should see what this file is.
Scrolling down. This should look pretty familiar. It's
just an HTML document. Going back to the Timeline,
let's get rid of some of these details. We can see a lot of events up here.
We click on this Filter button, it let's us get rid of
some of them so we can just look at what we want.
I just want to see the loading events, so we'll get rid of
scripting, rendering, and painting. And now, we can see the request for
the home page, and the response as we're receiving data. CNN.com finishes
loading, we get that HTML file, and then we start to parse
the HTML. And, it looks like in parsing it by opening up
this step, we see that we requested CSS and JavaScript. After that,
scrolling down, we can see more requests for all of the
scripts. Images and CSS files, that are needed to load the page.